wir sind in einem krankenhaus am
stadtrand den genauen ort möchte ich
nicht sagen aber ich möchte kurz
erzählen was hier ist also hier werden
natürlich auch die verletzten soldaten
eingeliefert der ukrainischen armee der
regulären ukrainischen armee und ich
möchte euch mal mitnehmen wir gehen
jetzt ins zimmer dr andré behandelt hier
die verletzten das sind alles junge
männer die wir hier sehen die eben jetzt
bei camp schwer verletzt wurden gegen
russische einheiten
wir sehen hier dr andré behandelt hier
auch die schussverletzung wir können
hier bitte gucken
ich möchte dr andré franke dr dre was
für verletzungen haben sie hier auf der
station mit was haben die soldaten hier
zu kämpfen kornelius griebl
nur
so in dem moment befindet sich hier auf
der station aber dann die soldaten die
also schusswunden haben oder später
wunden haben und diese soldaten
gesehen haben oder
haben er wurde dann im kampf verletzt
der hcd hat aber dann erzählt
schussverletzung im wurde aber dann die
abend durch gesten
dadurch ist ja aber dann hat er eine
schwere fraktur kann er erzählen was
hier mit diesem soldaten passiert ist
[Musik]
braun blieb
diese soldaten wurden angeschossen durch
die russin und der erleidet aber jetzt
an
durchschuss verwunderung kann er uns
erzählen was passiert ist wie ist er im
kampf verletzt worden wo war er mit
seiner einer chemotherapie
hier seine
wurde das war auch dann in lugansk
gebiet und sie sollten auch dann die
brücke verteidigen und die brücke wurde
aber dann durch die hosen mit granaten
beworfen und die russen auf solche weise
wollten aber dann vorbeifahren
durchfahren und und die brücke einnehmen
was ist dann passiert
und dann danach wurde er verwundet und
ihn später angebracht wie ist einfach
weniger ist er von einem panzer
beschossen worden wie waren die gefechte
etwas parade ja kooperativ wie peter ruf
der bank
das war ein schuss aus dem
maschinengewehr aus einem
maschinengewehr
gewusst ihm gegenüber
im scanner briten welche gemeint waren
sie aber dann eher in entfernung von
zehn metern also richtig gegenüber
kampf mann gegen mann
und gesicht ins gesicht glaubt er dass
es noch mehr russen dass es zu einem
häuserkampf kommt in der zukunft
[Musik]
ich meine ja wie soll das ausgehen
da war schon dunkel jagd selbst einmal
gesagt
also momentan weiß ich das nicht aber
ich hoffe
nicht hoffe ich bin ja mir sicher
besiegen wir hören hier die verletzten
soldaten wir gehen jetzt mal weiter dr
andré was ist hier mit diesem soldaten
passiert
[Musik]
roger irgendwie eklig dieser soldat
wurde aber dann am linken oberarm
verwundet und hat aber dann so eine
brandwunde am bus bekommen bei welchem
kampf ist das passiert möchte das mal
schildern wie er verletzt
[Musik]
wo die russin uns schon attackiert haben
wir waren in der schanze und sollten
mussten uns aber dann verteidigen und in
dem moment wurde verwundet
also durch eine patrone oder ein
projektil oder gerade hat er also das
wurde aber dann von der schanze
abgesprungen und ihn direkt unter die
schutzweste dar eingeflogen und dadurch
hat er an der diese brand verwundung
verletzung aber dann und das wurde ihm
in den oberen linken
reingesprungen getan oder eingedrungen
wem standen sie gegenüber einer
panzereinheit oder was hatten sie als
gegner
also das waren aber dann die feindliche
soldaten die erst mal beobachten wollten
naja sollte auch dann so einen sturm
geben mit panzer
einwohner bringt technik offen wie das
waren oder die leichten panzer peter
aber noch andere einheit nach welche
einheiten waren
die flugzeuge flogen auch dann immer
wieder herum
was eine freundin hatte er mal mit zu
hause telefoniert
machen sich seine eltern sorgen
geburtstag aber selbstverständlich
machen sich die eltern auch dann sorgen
um ihn und sie unterstützen und sagen
ihm immer wieder dass er sie dann
zusammen halten sollte zusammenreißen
sollte also wir sehen hier das sind
alles soldaten schicksale er hat uns
auch vorhin noch im vorgespräch gesagt
dass er eben auch schienen gesehen haben
will das sind männer mit langen
schwarzen bärten die eben auch in dieser
panzer ein etwa dr andré
ganz kurz noch wie
was benötigen sie wie schwierig ist es
jetzt in diesen krieg seiten auch
patienten zu behandeln zu betreten
koordinieren
also vor allen dingen muss ich ja sagen
dass wir die erste wie sind neutral den
müssen aber dann nur die die verwundeten
oder die kranken behandeln und alles was
wir noch oder was hier überhaupt
brauchen versorgt uns unserer stadt
damit
beratung problem
programm
natürlich haben wir probleme logistische
probleme aber dann versorgung mit
medikamenten und arzneimittel auch was
befürchtet er wenn die russen jetzt
weiter so die zivilisten auch
bombardieren wenn kiew eingenommen wird
und städte wie diese auch bombardiert
wird das ist ja der super gau das chaos
wurde
euro summieren
oslo gekostet alexander immig dass wir
ja sagt der herr doktor eine riesen
katastrophe
sein damit ihr das altern versteht in
der ersten linien dann leider die
zivilisten
gehört mit welchen sorgen und nöten
jetzt hier auch in diesen städten zu
kämpfen wird auch von medizinischer
seite das eben die soldaten auch jetzt
hier hin gekommen und ich fast dass kurz
zusammenhang befürchtet natürlich eben
durch die bombardierungen auch der
zivilen einrichtungen der zivilen
wohnräume dass es eben noch mehr
verletzten noch mehr tote gibt und dann
droht natürlich auch das
gesundheitssystem zu kollabieren dann
kann auch keine erstversorgung mehr
stattfinden und das ist eben die große
angst hier in dieser stadt vielen dank
peter hell live aus einem krankenhaus in
der ukraine und peter vielen dank auch
an deinen übersetzer